j'imite bruel
ça voilà depardieu mon nom voilà séché
au maximum de mes imitations
[Musique]
tout à fait oui vrai j'ai fini d'écrire
ma série astérix pour netflix mais
j'aimais on commence mais on commence
juste la prod là maintenant et donc
c'est la première fois qu'on travaille
sur un truc aussi gros parce que c'est
quand même cinq fois trente minutes avec
des gens absolument mythique dans
l'animé quoi
[Musique]
je passe beaucoup trop de temps sur
internet c'est vrai ouais beaucoup trop
de temps et maintenant beaucoup trop de
temps sur tik tok évidemment il ya plein
de merde mais il ya plein de trucs super
aussi je regarde des tutos de
dessinateurs par exemple ça j'aime bien
de danse parce que j'adore les danseurs
et danseuses et je sais pas danser quoi
donc je suis fasciné par les danseurs
quoi d'autre voie du la comédie quoi du
stand-up beaucoup de stand up
[Musique]
franchement le premier jour j'ai buggé
way j'étais tendu j'étais mieux j'étais
fan je savais que tout ce que je faisais
c'était foireux quoi c'était pas bien et
je voyais dans l'oeil de 2 de shon que
c'était pas top mais il était très
gentil et je voyais ben stiller aussi
qu'ils étaient très gentils mais je
sentais que tout le monde était super
déçu quoi de la performance que je
livrais et du coup voilà shine et il m'a
dit maintenant en fait on fait les plans
sur ben fait lui autre chose parce qu'il
a déjà entendu beaucoup le texte donc
essaye de le surprendre et dû faire des
trucs du coup je me suis dit au moins je
serve à ça dans cette journée donc je
vais fait plein de conneries plein de
trucs pour le essayer de le déstabiliser
puis de le garder la patate quoi et avec
le texte mais en étant plus libre
puisque l'on voyait juste un petit bout
de mon big horn pêche et shawn levy une
fois qu'il a eu toutes les prises avec
ben stiller valley ok maintenant on
refait sur toi c'est ça que c'est ça que
je veux il a été très gentil de
recommencer tout mécène sur moi en
basculant la lumière et tout est en en
faisant toutes les scènes que j'avais
franchement complètement [__] parce
que j'étais jeune j'avais trop le trac
quoi
[Musique]
ah oui c'est vrai je crois que j'avais
dû faire cette voie aux essais j'avais
fait des essais pour faire la voix
française de shrek savoir voilà enfin un
casting quoi j'avais fait j'avais fait
la voix de shrek qui est dans qui est
maintenant la voix de shrek et donc
qu'ils avaient dit oui mais est pris
pour ça et je crois je pense que j'avais
oublié ce que j'avais fait un peu et du
coup et j'ai dû j'ai dû refaire c'est
cette voie que j'avais trouvé sur le
moment je sais pas pourquoi j'ai fait 7
voilà quoi c'est jean paul rougier qui
travaillaient qui était un distributeur
qui m'apporte un jour une cassette vidéo
donc on est dans les années bissextiles
en noir et blanc avec du dreamworks
partout du mode copie tout c'est sur
l'image qu'on voyait presque rien et qui
me dit tiens on a un truc regarde pas ce
que ça peut te plairait le film qui le
truc était pas terminée en corse étaient
encore je trouve ça super drôle et j'ai
pour moi c'est un truc expérimental je
me dis tiens il faut un dessin animé un
peu chelou ça va être un one shot quoi
il va un peu bizarre un peu une niche
quoi
[Musique]
vrai j'ai déjà tourné avec james cameron
donc j'ai tourné une fausse pub parce
que c'était pour les nuls la mission
donc ça devait être en 91 james cameron
était en promo pour osi abysses et on
faisait une fausse pub autour de pétrole
m enfin il y avait une pub de pétrole n
y avait ce mec qui disait moi quand je
suis sur un tournage j'ai toujours le
temps de me frictionner la tête avec du
pétrole m et donc on avait fait une
campagne de sensibilisation pour dire si
vous voyez cette scène écrivait à
l'association des metteurs en scène qui
branle rien sur les tournages et pour
mettre un coup de tampon à cette
campagne de sensibilisation on avait
besoin de réalisateurs qui disaient ces
trucs là le premier était james cameron
et il l'a fait mais vraiment tellement
droit est tellement drôle que ce test
est magnifique quoi
[Musique]
alors oui il n'est pas basé sur moi mais
quentin dupieux l'a écrit en pensant à
moi et en se disant tiens que ce genre
de dialogue et c'est genre de phrase je
pourrai mais dire donc je pense qu'il a
pris des bouts de des bouts de moins en
tout cas donc oui c'est vrai
[Musique]
non j'ai pas menti pendant cette
interview